Hello, this is 6 Minute
English from BBC Learning English
I'm Neil and I'm Beth.
Now, you might know them
as aliens, UFOs,
little green men or even UAPs.
UAP stands
for unidentified anomalous phenomena
and it's the word scientists now use
to describe mysterious things
not from this world,. So Beth,
how would you feel if you looked up
and saw strange objects glowing
and twisting through the sky.
Wow!
Well, I might stare for a bit.
I don't know if I'd believe
what I was seeing
and I guess I'd be a bit scared.
Well, that situation is exactly what
navy pilots caught
on their fighter jet cameras
on a training flight
in 2004.
They recorded mysterious oval objects
flying at 24,000 metres.
The footage is known
as the 'tic tac' videos
and they have had millions
of views on Youtube.
Now, these videos are being reviewed
by US Congress to try to understand
what these objects were.
Were they flying saucers -
the disc shaped craft
flown by aliens?
Or is there
a more rational explanation?
In this programme, we'll be discussing
whether we are alone in the universe
and as usual, we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first, I have a question for you Beth.
Thousands of UFO sightings
are recorded every year.
But which country has had the
highest number of reported sightings
since records began,
according to the National UFO
Reporting Centre? Is it:
a) the USA
b) Canada or c) China?
Hmm, I think it must be the USA.
OK Beth, I'll reveal the answer
later in the programme.
Now, while astronomers are scientists
who study questions concerning things
outside of earth,
they often avoid investigating
supposed aliens.
Adam Frank,
professor of astrophysics
at the University of Rochester,
explains why
the footage in the tic tac videos
can't give any definitive answers
of alien life to BBC
World Service Programme,
'The Inquiry'.
Because I don't think
the pilots are lying,
you know, I think the pilots are being
honest and have a lot of integrity
about what they say they're seeing.
They're not saying they're aliens -
they're saying they behaved
in ways that no jet could behave.
But you know,
again, personal testimony -
you can't do any science with that.
So, what may happen now is we're going
to begin to get us some scientific study
of this and we'll try
and get a better handle on it.
Adam says the pilots have integrity,
a noun meaning to have honesty
and moral principles.
However, what they saw is based
on personal testimony.
A 'personal testimony' is a story
or statement of evidence supported
only by a person
and what they saw, rather than
any external evidence or hard facts.
To find out more about exactly what
the pilot saw, scientific studies
are being carried out to try and
get a better handle on the situation.
If you 'get a handle
on' something, you understand it
and are then able to deal with it.
Taking a more scientific approach
to what the pilot saw
the tic tac videos were examined by
a panel put together by NASA.
Here's Adam again,
discussing the findings on BBC
World Service Programme,
'The Inquiry'.
At the NASA panel,
one of the scientists showed
a simple analysis of the video
that shows the object travelling
seemingly at high speed over the ocean
and what the NASA scientist showed was
that with a simple analysis
you can show that that was moving
at forty miles-an-hour.
So certainly nothing
very extra-terrestrial about that.
The scientists found that
although it looks like
the object was travelling very fast,
it was only moving
at forty miles-an-hour,
which Adam says is not very
extra-terrestrial. Extra-terrestrial means
'from outside Earth', and is another
word often used to describe aliens.
So, it seems that for now,
scientists will need to find
much more proof to know exactly whether
we're alone in the universe or not.
OK Beth, I think it's time
I revealed the answer to my question.
I asked you which country has had
the highest number of reported sightings
since records began,
according to the National UFO
Reporting Centre.
And I guessed the USA.
Which was the correct answer,
there have been over
100,000 reported sightings
and encounters with UFOs in
the USA since 1947.
OK, let's recap the vocabulary
we've learned
from this programme, starting
with 'UAP' - an acronym that stands
for 'unidentified anomalous phenomena'
and is another word meaning
alien or UFO.
A 'flying saucer' is a disc-shaped
craft supposedly flown by aliens.
'Integrity' means being honest
in what you say and
having moral principles.
'A personal testimony' is a story
or statement
of evidence supported by a person
and what they saw, rather
than external evidence or hard facts.
If you 'get a handle
on' something you understand it
and are able to deal with it.
And finally 'extra-terrestrial' means
from outside Earth
and is another word
often used to describe aliens.
Once again,
our six minutes are up.
Join us again soon for more useful
vocabulary here at 6 Minute
English. Goodbye
for now. Bye!
If you like 6 Minute English,
why not try our News Review podcast,
where you can learn vocabulary
From the latest news
headlines,